cette semaine enfin depuis hier en
quelques semaines j'ai un nouveau
portable g1 autres numéros variés
j'ai pris ce numéro et j'ai envoyé à
plein de jeunes filles mais on a un
métier à yaya salut c'est qu'être simon
nouveau numéro non c'est pas on est pas
bien sais pas mais j'ai pas eu beaucoup
de réponses bien tant mieux mais j'en ai
eu certaines allées parmi les réponses
que j'ai eu il ya une jeune fille qu a
répondu très rapidement
aïe aïe aïe car à morgan a répondu et
samedi j'ai comme qui dirait passer la
seconde
badiane 4e
on a le premier message que j'ai regardé
salut à tous voici mon nouveau numéro
kers ou qui dit pas oublié déjà je dis
pas où je fais d'abord la balle a alors
tout est joué
je n'ai pas dit oui alors tu peux dire
c'est du goût car réponse à lui j'espère
que tu vas bien
hélas le ringard 2000 good ont des
conneries
nous dessinons gentil kendrick juste que
ce soit vrai donc je dis pas qu'ils ne
répondent pas et là je lui envoie ragga
3000 toi tu es bise
alors ça par contre je dis oui désolé
blake frye nez on trouve c'est toi qui
met black friday est ce que j'ai une
société mais c'est pas là des gens qui
travaillent là mais vous désolez black
friday bourgeois verriès avec plaisir je
serai à paris les bus semaine et
l'attendait un tabou ce mois j'avais
passé je glisse et lahi mélomanes et
l'autre dit que là le pauvre
ok je suis devenu ce que n'avait pas
exclu lundi des atomes en nette hausse
ce qui me gêne c'est que dans ta tête je
parle comme ça du tout mais c'est vrai
je portais mon sketch je pense et ce
qu'elle aurait fait autant c'est la
réponse c'est formidable laraque est
formidable c'est le e y aura qu il aura
qui ça veut dire j'espère qu'il aura du
monde
ou alors est-ce qu'on va être tout seul
si je peux me permettre voiture un petit
sms gentil freine un peu juste pour que
voilà ça se passe quand même 7 sms avant
le frein commun
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je me rappelle d'avoir envoyé des
arrivées au direct vous vous connaissiez
avant ou pas on s'était un tout petit
peu parlé mais des mets très légèrement
avec qui avec la passion toujours dans
le respect sur l'ativité auger du stock
disponible
c'est la seconde direct regarder la
suite apparemment tu n'as pas la carte
du web oui je dirais qu'on ne connaît
pas assez mais ça ça veut quand même
dire yens supporter
[Musique]
vous l'avez terme et la porte bab rabat
si je peux me permettre ce type encore
quelque chose
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est après mes larmes
en préambule
cyril je n'ai fait que respecter le
dresscode que tu avait exigé et je suis
dans ton équipe
le costume je sais que c'est les vannes
d'une boisson machin à damas ouais c'est
juste la seule est ce que tu peux la
nettoyer est-ce que c'est plus important
de parler des vêtements ou défendre une
femme qui se fâche s'est lamentablement
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
s'est pas posé une question à l'ensemble
de l'équipe j'aurais aimé qu'ils pensent
qu'ils bocquaine si on n'est pas fait ce
que lui verse laval applogic laquelle
avait fait ce qu'elle doit fermer la
porte tout de suite et de manière
grossière et la réponse est non mais non
je pense qu'elle a bien évolué
voilà mes chéris très bien qu'elle juge
à vis d'autres questions s'il vous plaît
maintenant avoir deux heures dans deux
heures il ya les mêmes sms de philippe
objections c'était bien défendu machine
oui ça te dit un verre à la maison ça
continue cette conversation commence à
me déplaire si je t'ai dit ok on boit un
verre
s'il voit déjà on voit un verre j'étais
énervé mais ce bois copie on se boit
quand alors souple alors quand il de
quoi qu'on se voit en voie celle ci
stopper et là j'avais emportements ma
position 1 selphy de kev adams attention
je fais clara morgane 1 face à ce moment
là je vais vous le dire
clara morgane elle envoie un sms
personnes et xénon sabine cyril est ce
que tu connais le numéro de madame son
numéro à kiev et jus mais attends je
vais vérifier
jamais
[Applaudissements]
je vais vérifier pourquoi elle m'a dit
on porte des bizarres jeudi c'est vrai
qu'il n'est pas très bien en ce moment
mais laquelle je t'aime moi je pense que
tu as demandé à série de personnes
langue c'est toi pour moi c'est ça ma
part
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors ces séries qui veut voir si ça
marche qui ont regardé la fin de la
conversation
[Applaudissements]
depuis qu'il a c'est moi je peux diriger
un jour tu reçois un texto
ouais mais ça sera ça de moi oui disant
tu veux à moi la nuit et après j'y suis
allé voilà je dis on se prend la tête
alors qu'on skiff sam bewley en fait tu
sera construit j'ai coupé parce qu'on a
un truc à construire ces bleus
voyez j'ai bloqué super lookée gains et
de la semoy deuxième chance pour moi
elle a rajouté chez ton poids santé
[Applaudissements]